Now that we've covered non-predictive
data analysis, let's switch gears, and
explore methodologies for
predicting an outcome.
The first step is to
investigate the data we have
available to solve the problem.
This will lead to one of
two possible outcomes.
We either have enough data
to solve the problem.
Which we'll classify as data rich.
Or we don't have enough
data to solve the problem,
which we'll classify as data poor.
There's a very simple way to determine
if you are data rich or data poor.
You can ask yourself, do you have data
on what you're trying to predict?
If so,
you can proceed down the data rich path.
Otherwise, the data poor
path is your only option.
What may not be clear right now is
understanding whether you have data on
what you're trying to predict.
Let's use an example to illustrate and
clarify the concept.
[BLANK_AUDIO]